das NATO-Hauptquartier in Brüssel hier
laufen die strategischen Fäden zusammen
um die Ukraine zu unterstützen und
Europa vor einem möglichen Angriff
Russlands zu schützen
das Wort vom Atomkrieg macht die Runde
die Militärübung sei aber keine weitere
Eskalation
es werden 50 Flugzeuge den belgischen
Himmel überfliegen unser Ziel bleibt
aber das gleiche wir wollen eine
strategische Lage erreichen in der nicht
mehr weiter eskaliert wird und sich die
Konfliktparteien an einen Tisch setzen
um den Krieg zu beenden
den Krieg beenden und gleichzeitig sich
auf das Schlimmste vorbereiten
vor den Augen der Weltöffentlichkeit
versucht die NATO diese Balance
hinzubekommen
Putin scheint verzweifelt und
verzweifelte sind gefährlich die
Atomwaffen des Bündnisses und die
Militärübungen sollen Putin abschrecken
sie sind hier gelagert um eben die
europäische Sicherheit direkt an die
us-sicherheit quasi zu koppeln und hier
Russland eben klar zu machen dass eine
eine Aggression gegen nato-bündnis
Territorium die USA direkt involvieren
würde das heißt das Ziel ist hier
Abschreckung und Verteidigung
auf den Gängen des EU-Parlaments
diskutieren Sie die Gefahr eines
Atomkrieges gerade die baltischen
Abgeordneten die sich vor Russlands Nähe
fürchten sind besonders besorgt
die russischen Raketenangriffe auf die
Infrastruktur der Ukraine zeigen Putin
eskaliert weiter er will den
Widerstandswillen der Ukraine zerstören
und deshalb muss Russland
eskalieren ich hoffe dass es nicht so
ein nuklearen Eskalation kommen wird
aber ich schließe das nicht mehr aus
um dies zu verhindern warnt er
EU-Außenbeauftragte Barrel Russland und
diplomatisch direkt
jeder nuklear-angriff auf die Ukraine
wird mit einer scharfen Reaktion
beantwortet es wird nicht eine nuklearen
Gegenschlag geben aber die Reaktion wird
so machtvoll militärisch sein dass sie
das russische Militär vernichten wird
die Bilder der letzten Militärübung
wirken fast harmlos da gab es noch
keinen Krieg in Europa
jetzt ist der Kontinent ein Pulverfass
und die heutige Übung bitterer Ernst
und Christine Lambrecht ist bei uns die
bundesverteidigungsministerin schönen
guten Morgen guten Morgen Roland Brecht
wir haben gerade unseren kursmänton
der Kontinent ist ein Pulverfass wie
real ist die Gefahr eines Atomkrieges
also man muss ganz genau beobachten was
Russland momentan macht und die
Drohungen auch nicht verharmlosen oder
als bluffabton sondern ernst nehmen aber
ernst nehmen bedeutet ja dann nicht sich
davon leben zu lassen sondern genau
beobachten und das machen wir jetzt auch
in Bezug auf Übungen die stattfinden
genau zu schauen ist das was
ursprünglich geplant war wird das
genauso ablaufen oder wird es länger
diese Übung dauern und was können daraus
für Schlüsse gezogen werden das ist
jetzt das Gebot der Stunde sehr besonnen
sein aber eben auch genau beobachten und
dann vorbereitet sein das nato-manöver
ist ja das eine das auch jedes Jahr
stattfindet aber werden denn bei der
Bundeswehr auch mögliche Szenarien
durchgespielt für einen möglichen
Atomangriff auf Deutschland wie sind wir
denn da vorbereitet wir sind eingebunden
wir sind eine Bündnis Armee und
selbstverständlich stimmen wir uns im
Bündnis in der NATO ab und haben das
auch beispielsweise letzte Woche beim
Treffen der Verteidigungsminister in
Brüssel gemacht aber ich bitte auch um
Verständnis das sind eben auch
Entscheidungen oder Abstimmungen die
dann auch aus strategischen Gründen
geheim bleiben sollten aber es ist
wichtig vorbereitet zu sein es ist
wichtig besonnen zu sein und es ist
wichtig zu beobachten würde sagen wir
sind vorbereitet auf jeden Fall die
Frage der nuklearen Abschreckung ist das
eine seit Kriegsbeginn auch die Frage
der militärischen Unterstützung der
Ukraine die EU-Außenminister geben heute
den Startschuss für die Ausbildung von
15.000 ukrainischen Soldaten außerhalb
der Ukraine was ist da der deutsche
Beitrag wir werden ganz erkannt uns
daran beteiligen wir haben das schon
gemacht wir haben ja ukrainische
Soldaten beispielsweise schon an der
Panzerhaubitze 2000 ausgebildet
angebraten am mehrfachraketenwerfern
IRST und wir werden diese Fähigkeiten
die wir haben jetzt noch erhöht
einbringen das heißt es wird Ausbildung
geben am gef Übungszentrum wir haben
Simulatoren alles das was wir haben
werden wir nutzen so wie die Ukraine es
braucht denn das ist das wichtige dass
die Ukraine sagt jetzt können wir euch
Soldaten schicken jetzt ist diese
Ausbildungs ist diese Ausbildungsbedarf
und da werden wir sehr flexibel dann uns
daran beteiligen gleichzeitig muss die
NATO ja darauf achten dass sie nicht
selbst Kriegspartei gibt es gab ein
wissenschaftliches Gutachten vor ein
paar Monaten das wissenschaftlichen
Dienstes des Deutschen Bundestages der
aussagt dass schon die Ausbildung von
ukrainischen Soldaten auf deutschem
Boden oder europäischen Boden eine
Kriegsbeteiligung sein kann also wie
schmal ist da der Grad also die
Einschätzung teile ich nicht das aber
ist auch eine rein theoretische
Diskussion denn da wir liefern Waffen
und dann finde ich ist es auch unsere
Verpflichtung dass wir an diesen
Waffensystem an diesen hochkomplexen
Waffensystemen wir dann auch ausbilden
das gehört dann mit dazu und dieser
Verantwortung kommen wir auch den
Soldaten den ukrainischen Soldaten
gegenüber nach aber wir achten natürlich
sehr genau darauf und diese
ausbildungsmission wird eine
eu-ausbildungsmission sein es ist immer
wichtig die NATO ist keine Kriegspartei
wir als Bundesrepublik werden keine
Kriegspartei das ist eine
eu-ausbildungsmission und daran werden
wir uns sehr signifikant beteiligen die
Bundesregierung beteiligt sich ja daran
auch an den Waffenlieferungen jetzt mit
einem neuen Luftabwehrsystem das in
Deutschland jetzt noch gar nicht zum
Einsatz kam das sozusagen wenn ich es
richtig verstanden habe direkt vom
Hersteller in die Ukraine geliefert wird
vier hat Bundeskanzler Scholz
versprochen im Juni 1 ist bisher
geliefert von diesen neuartigen
Luftabwehrsystem dass die Ukraine das
gut brauchen kann haben wir heute morgen
wieder gesehen an den Luftangriffen in
Kiew warum ist der erst eins geliefert
und wann werden die anderen drei
geliefert die anderen drei werden im
Laufe des nächsten Jahres geliefert so
wie die Industrie als leisten kann ich
würde mir da auch wünschen ich könnte
auch vier in irgendeinem Lager
zurückgreifen aber so etwas gibt es
nicht das ist leider durch das Sparen in
den letzten Jahren völlig versäumt
worden auch dass wir jetzt endlich uns
daran machen die Lücken auch in
europäischen
Luftverteidigungssystem zu schließen
auch das ist geschuldet dass diese
Lücken da sind dass sie bisher nicht
geschlossen wurden da müssen wir uns
ranmachen sowohl mit der Unterstützung
der Ukraine schnellstmöglich bin froh
dass dieses irist-system früher
geliefert werden konnte als ursprünglich
geplant weil auch die Industrie sich da
noch mal richtig reingehängt hat und es
jetzt schneller gehen konnte und es ist
so wichtig wir sehen es ja
Luftverteidigung ist momentan das
wichtigste was die Ukraine braucht um
sich gegen diese Terrorangriffe zu
wehren was damit der Bevölkerung
geschieht ist unfassbar es ist so
belastend und deswegen ist es gut wenn
wir dieses System jetzt liefern auch
wenn wir sie gerne in Deutschland gehabt
hätten nun kommt der Herbst und der
Winter und der Krieg geht immer noch
weiter was glauben Sie was die nächsten
Monate in diesem Konflikt bringen werden
wir werden auf jeden Fall erstmal als
Bundesrepublik dafür sorgen dass wir die
Ukraine unterstützen in Bezug auf
Winterausrüstung Bezug auf Zelte in
Bezug auf Stromaggregate aber auch in
Bezug auf winterausrüst
damit eben dieser kalten Jahreszeit dann
auch getrotzt werden kann und mal weiter
kämpfen kann aber es wird sich verändern
dadurch der der Kriegsverlauf aber wir
dürfen nicht die Hoffnung haben dass
jetzt deswegen
Ruhe einkehren wird das wird nicht sein
wir sehen ja wie die wie Russland ganz
gezielt auch verändert hat die Strategie
und jetzt auch gezielt Infrastruktur
angreift und eben auch Zivilbevölkerung
also da hoffen dass jetzt im Winter sich
etwas deutlich verändert ins Positive
diese Hoffnung habe ich nicht sagt die
Bundesministerin für Verteidigung
Christine Lambrecht vielen Dank dass Sie
heute morgen arbeiten danke schön danke